Secondhand Smoke - A Major Health Hazard.
Winston, would you please put out that cigarette?
I hate cigarette smoke!
Besides, I'm sure you know how hazardous secondhand smoke is.
If you care about me, please stop smoking while I'm around.
Or, better yet, I think you should quit smoking cold turkey!
You know I'm saying this for your own good.
I see what you mean,...
...but it's really hard for me to quit smoking now!
I'm under a lot of stress these days...
...and smoking is the only way to release the stress.
I know I'm pathetic, but you're going to have to bear with me.
About secondhand smoke, I see your point, Jaime,...
...that it affects your health as much as it damages my health.
But, as for me, I have to protest.
Do you want me to go outside the building whenever I need a cigarette break?
Then I'm going to have to leave my computer every half an hour.
That's not productive!
Plus, smoking helps me focus better.
So, I suggest that you move your desk to another room for now!